his childhood home must have been here
somewhere Klaus teal was 9 when he had
to flee his hometown costume which was
destroyed by Soviet bombers in the
Second World War desertion it lazu it
was a brutal rupture from one day to the
next we were nothing Dominique's
nowadays the town is part of Poland the
journalist spends a lot of time here
these days he is showing to polish
treasure hunters were part of his family
legacy his history might be buried in
the plots that was the common dance
headquarters why here's my house number
22 the pool took two but little remains
of it they're trying to unearth the
cellar teal wants to get in there CFE to
show in abuja i have a lot of beautiful
books down here my relatives have some
real treasures down there silver cutlery
for 24 people in porcelain but and my
mother had something that was very
valuable back at at least 20 jars full
of potted meat the family was forced to
leave almost everything behind the same
was true of some 12 million Germans who
fled or were expelled as Nazi Germany
crumbled teal dreams of finding a
memento of the past but it's not looking
good the seller is too deeply buried we
need completely different machinery to
dig here in Joanna's of the tadka patch
to you it's a tragedy with what else can
I say the men try their luck next door
perhaps they can get into the cellar of
Till's childhood home from there while
teal waits above ground the
professionals creep into the cellar of
the former pharmacy German soldiers
weren't trenched here during the battle
for the town entry is prohibited the
treasure hunters from the Association
called cocoon could be risking their
lives butch is God when the bomb hit the
house the whole top story collapsed this
could give way at any mall
lantus lunch it's a dangerous endeavor
but teal is pleased with the results the
treasure hunters bring him objects that
belong to the houses inhabitants
awakening memories of his childhood more
than 70 years ago which the light
theatre collection watch a very
expensive porcelain England is an
inkwell inside a small shell brought
home from the Baltic for me each of
these objects awakens emotions even if
they didn't belong to my family maybe
they belong to people i knew the
treasure seekers are unable to reach the
seller of his childhood home teal isn't
sure whether he'll continue the hunt but
he says retrieving parts of his
childhood in this way is a healing
process